we're such [__] children show Colleen
show Colleen hey show Khalid hey Colleen
are you coming yet are you coming
she's not but I am these pics are great
dude
[Music]
so uh a new doctor has come out on Tick
Tock and has warned people against
getting surgery to enlarge their penis
wait that actually exists this is
terrible news but then do you lose the
nerves because then what's the point of
having a big dick if you can't feel oh
you have to walk around with a big old
dick though
there's two different operations to
lengthen it or to Gerson it girth in it
you do both at the same time yeah I
think it's highly not recommended but
someone's gonna die in there you gotta
choose why doctors well actually it's
going what did she just say
look it's like a groundbreaking it's
like Jesus Christ then he puts the
formula on glass and he's like it works
holy [__]
Eureka
y equals NX plus girl he goes out to the
floor and he throws papers in the air
and everyone's like what no way and they
started doing like a NASA style
handshakes
there's a guy who's like who's like he's
like in a room far away and he's like
they're gonna go through he's like they
don't it's gonna blow up this thing's
gonna blow up
they don't know no there's a guy there's
a guy who turns around and goes
you know that's never gonna work
the jaded veteran yeah
he's in a wheelchair though I tried yeah
his legs are gone bro
1972.
they're never gonna make it happen you
think it's my choice to walk like this
he's like he's like at least I'm alive
you should see my wife come to a
headstone oh it's in the room
right over there
oh my God so this doctor explains that
there are two types two types of
procedures one two like I said lengthen
the penis and another to give it more
girth
um one is you cut the suspension
ligament and that makes the penis look
longer I don't think they should cut
that bro that sounds like it's important
it sounds like it's important and he
says now that's great for the men's
change room because that's what all guys
do you'll go into a change room show
everybody your dicks let's go it's an
optical illusion but for actual
intercourse it actually reduces function
and it can make the penis unstable and
you can break your penis see I would
much rather not do that so it's like a
Magic Eye it's a Magic Eye dick it just
makes it look bigger don't look directly
at it look up here look from over there
it's like trying to get a dick angle to
make it look as big as possible oh no
what about if you Contour your dick with
like makeup there has to be a way dude
Contour give your dick a little outline
there she goes that abs are like their
faces I watch female makeup videos with
my wife I see what they'd be doing in
their face there's got to be a way can
you just go into Mac and just be like
okay what can you do about this can you
fixing me up I got a hot date today
going to Sephora what do you got lady
the best ways to get arrested I've heard
in a while
in a while in a minute and then they'll
let you go
the suspensory ligament plays a major
role in proper penis functioning and so
it's important to avoid injury to this
tissue unless you want your junk to stop
working
ligaments don't have the same ability to
heal naturally like other parts of the
body especially when they're completely
torn so that's not a good one that's a
lot of risk I was thinking about the
make Macy's makeup ladies
dude they can't wait to talk to you
that's true they're like we'll see what
we can do they're like wow someone
someone's coming right for us it's my
lucky day she's gonna be like you
looking for something for your wife
actually it's something for me
would you be bothered if you were dating
a guy and then he confessed that oh
actually I had my dick looking I don't
think any guy would admit to that person
what if you found his paperwork well
have you found his paperwork like his
certification just pulling down the
[__] sun visor in the car and it just
drops
enjoying the moment like hey what's this
would that bother you at all would it
bother me yeah um it'd bother me if it
doesn't work what if it works great what
if it works great and then you look at
it and it's still only three inches
though
he enlarged it from one to three yeah
you're like wait you got LinkedIn it was
still three inches
a small ass stick and he's like I got a
confession I've had lengthening
procedures so you went from small and
you're too small to small she's just
like oh really oh really I didn't think
suspension too but [__] I didn't think
you needed it I said cut the line doc
I'm lighting out there so the other
technique uh is this one this one sounds
disgusting to add um
why every article you have been playing
so far is their old Steve Irwin videos
playing around
every single [__] I'm not kidding for
everything
this guy likes animal videos it was on
this app yeah it was on this ad here is
old Stever it's like old Stever with a
snake on it it's your cookies dude
Irwin's been popping up on my Instagram
see what's going on did you see the
world where the [__] snake bit his
neck yeah yeah that's what this was what
why is that going around there there was
something recent about him maybe maybe
it's the anniversary of his death or
some [__] maybe just the snake relevance
to this dick thing oh that could be
that's pretty good search terms that
makes sense
so you like snakes do ya look at this
procedure as a surgery you have to
inject fat into the penis to make it
thicker that sounds way cooler dude hey
that's what people say I want a fat dick
but have you seen have you actually seen
how those look no I haven't look those
look pretty gnarly yeah it says that you
can get lumps and bumps in your penis
and it's going to be uneven pull one up
and then show your face man oh man it
really does look pretty crazy all right
here let me go incognito on it what do I
even [__] put in this fat injected
dick that injected and then just write
Anthony
by Anthony Lee a poem I went to shop
see Steve Irwin tackling the crocodile
oh my God
yeah it's not good let me see let me see
it doesn't look so clean so clean so
Colleen we're such [__] children show
Colleen show Colleen hey Colleen are you
coming yet are you coming
she's not but I am these pics are great
dude
oh [__] the most childish I've ever seen
that's so [__] funny
yo this is wild oh my God
okay there's penises out there
eight out of ten
out of 10. that's a top right holy [__]
oh no that's like when those [__]
fake ass bodybuilders want to inject
that [__] oh dude
that's crazy I remember so why do I even
get the procedure if clearly there's not
great uh I think it's up here more yeah
a little bit but what if it works what
if it works you guys ever heard about
dudes uh it's not working
you guys ever heard about guys putting
marbles in their dick and yeah I seen
that yeah they put in the top so they've
been like oh when I get out man I'm a
[__] plow my girl down and then
they're like oh well you better put
marbles in your dick then and then they
you're talking about in prison right
yeah in prison I don't know first of all
I don't know how they get monsters why
do they have so many marbles in prison
how do they sneak it in dude always
playing marbles oh yeah it's probably
been in someone's [__] or something
you know maybe it's an easy thing to
smuggle through your butt yeah and then
you can play marbles or something but
they got marbles you play board games
and then they cut the penis and they
stuff it through and I'm like that is a
brutal procedure to do and can you just
imagine two cell buddies two cell
buddies sitting there one guy's in
between his [__] legs no painkillers
nothing no no alcohol whatever that
gives me like uh it's it's like for for
extra pleasure for the woman all like
adding beads in there like oh
so if it's like this it's like it's like
right at the top so it goes hits the G
is that true though
I don't know ask Colleen
um
you gotta get out more yeah
but yeah now the the outside of prison
people they just put like hearts and
[__] they'll do like these like metal uh
like uh implants
yeah they'll do designs a little
lightning like IUD yeah yeah exactly not
like that at all
this is new to me I don't know
it's a safe space but it's also very
dangerous it's more like it's more like
a wfd
anthy's Googling big dicks
being the surgery does it work every
time he's searching other stuff now you
should type in Marble dick did you type
yeah
oh yeah you want to check how that looks
the marble on the Dick God damn it I
only do it to show Colleen I don't know
if I want to watch this bro it's exactly
no it's less gross than the fat
injection oh the fat injection's bad
that [__] looks like a [__] gooey
duck this just looks like a Dr pimple
popper this is just a lot of Greek
statues you said marble oh [__] oh he
likes it I gotta try this oh oh it's a
screen oh [__] all right show clean
she'll clean yeah all right bring it
here oh come on Kelly check it out oh
dude that's not okay bro
rib for your pleasure though that looks
like warts is that warts yeah that
doesn't it looks like a tumor a lot of
statins it would be a an immediate no I
think everything would cease yeah do you
guys see Suicide Squad it looks like
that spot guys oh yeah the dude who
[__] like gets all puffed up vomited
there is a lot of statues what do you
mean really though yeah
that's a wonderful one oh that's a bad
example
he said that's a wonderful one Ryan
stuck his tongue out he was like I want
a 3D me
it's definitely up here definitely up
here if you're gonna do that to your
body you're [__] mentally do you
think girls are like I can't wait till
my guy gets out of prison so he could
[__] me down with his marble dick
absolutely but to be sure let's ask
Colleen sure we have a lady here I
should I I think they can't wait yeah
yeah right yeah I can do it I can't is
it something that gets said at every
cocktail party probably all the ladies
uh that are like oh my my man's coming
out of prison I can't wait he told me he
got two implanted oh well mine's got
three and then they fight over it yeah
they lose a friendship yeah and they
fight over they're just like well so
what and then they all laugh at the girl
that has a guy that only has one marble
what if it made the sex worse
so then you get this operation and then
made the sex worse oh for both parties
reasonable what have you got two Marbles
and you have sex and then you come out
you only have one marble left oh [__]
maybe they should ask what Joe just did
is why I miss when guys used to write
movie scripts for girls yeah
they were the best yeah it was the best
it's like oh my God my guy's gonna come
out and he's gonna dick me so hard with
his marble dick I'm like oh yeah well
he's my guy's gonna make me come way
harder and faster
you only have one Marvel yeah measure
the measure the table read for that yeah
just marble dick that's the title of
this donde esta marble
because it gets lost right
[Music]
foreign